（ら～らら、さぁ輪になって踊ろうラララララ）「あわわわわわー」
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
季節的には冬なので
皆さんの地域によっては雪がふっているかもしれない。
また、朝寒すぎて
家の道路が
凍り付けになってるかもしれない。
ですよね！
冬はやっぱり気温が低いので
雪が降ったり氷が張って
床が滑ることがあるんっすよ！
つるっつるにね！
僕も富山県出身なんで
雪の怖さは知ってるんすよ！
氷の危険さもね！
滑ってこけてね
頭とかをうつと
ほんとに危ないんで。
そうゆうことのために、こうゆう道具があります。
プルプルプルプルプルプルプルプルプルプルプルプル
？！”＃＄％＆’’＆％＄＃”！＜＞？＿＿？＞＃＄％
ベンドゥン
コロバンド～！
これネーミングセンスが疑わ
靴用滑り止めでございます。
こうゆう感じでね
靴につけることによって
その靴が滑らなくなるみたいです。
大面積で安心歩行足にやさしい設計ということで。
蹴ったりするときも全然大丈夫みたいなんで。
これさえ付ければ氷とか雪とかの道も余裕で歩けるんすよ。
コロバンドというものがあるんすけれども。
まあ、滑らないということは
場所を問わないんだと思います。
あ！こういう感じね！
うわ！こうゆう感じか。
こうゆう感じでございます。
右と左がちゃんとあります。
靴に取り付けるってこうゆう感じかな？
あっ！ちょっと小さくね？大丈夫？
あ！こうゆう感じです。
ここで滑りが止まるみたいです。
（パン！）
はい、というわけで右、左ばっちりでございます。
この靴を履くことによって・・
これ大丈夫？？
ほんとに滑んないよね？？
たぶん大丈夫だと思う。
滑らないって書いてあるから。
大丈夫だとおもう！
家の床をローションだらけにします。
で！その上を
僕がもうこれをつけて全力疾走しますよ！
ローション塗りまくって滑る道を
安心して。
確実に一歩一歩踏みしめれるか
というのをや見ようとと思います、でわいこう！
ほっ！
はい、というわけであっ！
はい！とういうわけでここが今日の会場です。
この道に今からブルーシートをひきます。
で！ひいたブルーシートの上に
ローションを塗って
そこでさっきの滑り止め付の靴が歩きます。
いや！走ります！！
走りますとも。
走るよ。
走って
もう大丈夫だよ、俺は信じてるよ
もう滑らないって言ったら滑らないんすよ！
僕は体を張って検証するんで走ります！
早送り▶▶
なんか思ったより大変だな・・
こんなもんでしょ!!
ひとまずローションを引ける環境は作りました。
ローション塗っていきます。
俺さなんでこんなこと考えたんだろう？
さっき静岡から帰ってきたばっかりなんすよ。
で、明日は東京だしさ。
たぶん本当はねぇローション塗っている暇ないんだとおもう。
それでもさやりたいんだよ。
～（決め顔）～
では、いきま～す。
うわ～
あ～～～
どうでしょうか。
あ！これやばいっぞ
あああああ～～～ああああ～～
本番はここからですからね。
今から実際に靴を履いて
本当に滑らないかどうかを確かめてみようと思います。
でわいこう！
ちょっと危ないからヘルメットかぶるね。
俺ここで死ぬわけにはいかねえからな。
とういうわけでこちらの二つですね。
シュべり止め
滑り止めをした靴を二つ使って
ちょっと歩いてみようと思います。
さっきあんだけ滑ったからたぶん大丈夫だと思うんだけども・・
はいではパパッといってみようと思います。
大丈夫！
俺なら出来る！
いきます。
スリー
トゥー
ワン
お！！
滑らない！！
えっ！！かなり滑らない！！
えっ！まって本当に滑らないほら！
これすごくね？
えっ！まってほんとに滑らない！
えっ！やったーー！！！
うわーーーー
あっあ
ああ
字幕審査 0777hmajj    ※間違い、誤字脱字がある場合は報告して下さい。
エンディング♬～